some of the best TV series of all time
were cancelled too soon but those
overlooked classics at least had enough
episodes air to build up a fan base that
was devastated when the shows were
pulled before their time imagine how it
must feel to be a creator producer or
star of a TV series that perform so
poorly that it was ripped off the air
after only a single episode here are
some shows that share that very
unfortunate distinction co-ed fever the
biggest movie comedy of 1978 was
National Lampoon's Animal House so
naturally all three broadcast TV
networks at the time looked to cash in
on the craze
CBS's attempt co-ed fever was canceled
before it even debuted in its regular
timeslot fording countless wacky hijinks
[Music]
after the TV premiere of rocky in 1979
CBS had some time to fill and aired a
special preview of the show which was
set on the campus of a former women's
college that had just started admitting
men while the show ranked a reasonable
19th in the Nielsen ratings for the week
it lost so much of the Rocky audience
that CBS shut it down completely public
morals in the 80s and 90s producer
Steven Bochco the creator of critically
acclaimed hits shows such as NYPD Blue
Hill Street Blues in LA Law was just
about the king of TV CBS jumped at the
chance to get into the botch Co business
and committed the laugh track laid in
public morals to its fall 1996 scheduled
ratings and reviews for its October
debut were dismal and a show about a
vice squad also suffered from bad timing
it premiered in an election year that
included a debate over whether TV was
growing too vulgar because of shows like
public morals CBS canceled it after just
one controversial airing emily's reasons
why not
ABC reportedly spent five million
dollars on an ad campaign for the
mid-season launch of emily's reasons why
not a 2006 sitcom about how dating is
hard and weird
starring the always likeable Heather
Graham Graham starred is Emily a woman
unlucky in love trying to figure out who
not to date and why viewers must have
decided there were plenty of reasons why
not to give the show a chance it lost
more than a third of the audience of its
lead in and lost a quarter of the
audience of The Bachelorette the show
that had occupied its timeslot a year
earlier which led to ABC immediately
pulling the plug
secret talents of the stars one part
circus of the stars one part American
Idol this reality competition show
featured celebrities known for one
talent demonstrating a different talent
the general public didn't know they had
just over 4.5 million people tuned in to
watch to mention just one representative
example country singer Clint Black try
stand-up comedy tonight viewers at home
are supposed to vote for their favorites
each week had CBS not canceled the show
after its first episode in 2008 quarter
life high quality TV streaming on the
internet it's common today but in 2008
it was revolutionary
Marshall Hershkovitz and Edward Zwick
creators have critically acclaimed
dramas thirtysomething and my so-called
life debuted quarter life on myspace
which was a hot social media platform at
the time the show was made to reflect
its medium episodes were short and
resembled YouTube clips and it looked
like it was shot on webcams or hidden
cameras while there was no real
precedent for what constituted a hit
streaming series in 2008 enough people
watched that NBC decided to put it on
terrestrial television after taking a
few episodes and pacing them together to
fit an hour-long programming block its
premiere brought in just 3.1 million
viewers the worst mid-season ratings of
an NBC show in nearly two decades the
network canceled the show and dumped the
five remaining prepared episodes onto
its cable counterpart Bravo south of
Sunset Eagles singer and guitarist Glenn
Frey didn't fare nearly as well in his
foray into dramatic television as he
done with smooth California rock very
few viewers got a peaceful easy feeling
with south of Sunset a lightly comic
detective show in which Frey starred as
a former movie studio security chief who
opens his own private investigations
company in Beverly Hills
despite CBS frequently airing ads for
the show during its broadcast of the
1993 World Series just before the
premiere episode only 9% of viewers tune
their dials to south of Sunset the Los
Angeles Times reported that the show
amassed Lois
premiere ratings on record for a show on
one of the big three networks to date
CBS put the show on hiatus almost
immediately but south of Sunset never
returned to the schedule
Osbourne's reloaded an attempted revival
of MTV's The Osbournes Osbourne's
reloaded debuted in a plum post American
Idol timeslot in 2009 it presented metal
God Ozzy Osbourne and his family at the
center of a variety show featuring
pre-taped segments sketches audience
participation bits and musical
performances following a high-profile
preview episode nearly one in five Fox
affiliates refused to air further
episodes of Osborne's reloaded due to
concerns over racy material and bad
language critics were brutal The
Washington Post called it a revolting
debacle and must flee TV Fox didn't even
bother to air the rest of the episodes
already in the can lawless Fox
apparently didn't learn much from CBS's
disastrous south of sunset and ordered
up another series about a private
investigator starring a famous non actor
lawless starred standout University of
Oklahoma linebacker and Seattle Seahawks
washout Brian the Boz Bosworth as an ex
Special Forces tough guy named John
lawless who unravels mysteries in Miami
very few people wanted to see the Boz
off the gridiron and Fox canceled in
1997 series after its premiere episode
it doesn't seem to be your lucky day
thanks for watching click the looper
icon to subscribe to our YouTube channel
plus check out all the school stuff we
know you'll love to
[Music]